everything with you is about time isn't
it ah the president the future kids
working with senator you know all of it
right you know our strength
you know our fears he's my best friend
you know how much we love each other and
you know how to use that love again I
know who you are is about Todd
flash moment is Tuesday at 8/7 central
on the CW
hey youtubers is Charlie saboteur is
finally unmasked and it seems like what
they're implying is is that he will open
up the costume for Barry and they'll
finally reveal it to us the audience
whose avatar is so I made this video
just a little bit longer than I would
normally make for a trailer video just
because we need to talk about the what
reveal the why how it makes sense some
of the logic and look back at some of
the clues that they've given us like
this moment from episode 9 so just
remember that a lot of times they'll
tell us things that don't make sense
after they reveal what the big twist is
that was kind of the lesson from zoom
when they explained the twist behind
that it didn't completely make sense
when you look at the entire season so
there are a couple things the teaser is
implying visually about who the identity
of saboteur is in there's some clues and
Barry's dialogue and then somatically
there have been some clues this season
so there's a new brand of the flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber leave a comment on this
video so to be careful if you're laying
money on this because there are a lot of
mr. X so there are a couple important
things that are happening to the actual
plot of the episode I know we're all
just wondering who's avatar is we're
waiting for that moment where he opens
up and Barry's like I know who you are
it's about time and then boom we finally
get the money shot but the Tracy Brand
character is making her debut so team
flash is now trying to find her because
Barry has her hard drive and at the same
time killer frost is now working with
sabot R and is going after Tracy brand
too so that looks like where these
scenes are taking place here where you
have full-blown 5 vs. killer frost
so like danielle Panabaker T's we're
getting a version of that future fight
between vibe and killer frost but it
looks like it's happening in a different
place than the place where Cisco got his
hands frozen off although he's still
grimace making that same expression to
like oh my god this hurts so the Tracy
brand set seems like a completely new
location that we haven't seen before
maybe it'll be a regular thing but I
think the idea is is that if she
survives to season 4 and I hope she does
because I like the actress I like the
idea of her joining the team she would
just come to StarLab so this place might
be a temporary thing and it does look
like they trash a pretty hardcore in
their fight but let's talk about the
really big way that they're
foreshadowing saboteurs identity of this
now they could be a little misleading
but I like the way they visually
try to tell us who's avatar is without
verbally telling us so in the opening
moment of the teaser fairy steps into a
pool of water on the ground that's
reflecting savat are so sabotage
reflection and berry are both inside
that pool so I think they're trying to
say thats avatar is a dark reflection of
berry at least visually that's what
that's telling us it could still be
someone else because berry says you're
all about time you know how much we love
each other so what are you saying in
that dialogue is thats avatar
understands the way they feel about each
other it's not just an informational
thing like eobard thawne when he was
first trying to find berry
so eobard thawne in season 1 lived with
them for 10 years he understood how much
team flash cared about each other he
understood their relationships he'd
spent a lot of time with them so the
only person who would understand how
much team flash loves each other is
somebody who's been a member of team
flash and I know a lot of people want to
believe that it's Ronnie after that
Caitlyn twist at the end of the last
episode in the problem with the Ronnie
twist is that Ronnie himself didn't
fully understand everybody on team flash
he spent a little bit of time with them
and he definitely loved Caitlin but he
didn't know them the way core flash team
members know each other so nobody hurts
you like your friends so it goes way
beyond hunter zolomon zoom pretending to
be Jay Garrick on a team for a single
year the way Barry talks about sabotage
sabotage knows team flash members way
better than zoom or eobard thawne knew
them so just visually unless they're
being very misleading it's almost like
they're trying to tell us that it's
Barry but like I said it could still be
a number of other people so I wouldn't
lay any money on this with your friends
do not bet money on this because
sometimes TV shows can be very
misleading with their twist and think
about it this way a lot of you have
pointed out the weirdness of that line
of dialogue my child why would Ronnie or
even Barry call Caitlin their child and
then you look at this episode 9
flashback and this definitely looks a
little bit like Ronnie this does not
look like Barry unless he got super
jacked like look at his traps look at
those biceps that does not look like
Grant Gustin it could be Ronnie but it
looks more like a bodybuilder so there's
a lot of misleading evidence in a lot of
unreliable
so like when jay garrick talks about
myths he could have been an unreliable
narrator so there's still a lot of big
question marks in ways that they need to
sew up their logic because a lot of
times they haven't completely worked the
logic out the time remnant thing with
Jay Garrick and zoom I think that that's
something that they came up with at the
last minute a lot of people complained
about that twist during season two
that's how you explain all this
weirdness with zoom killing other
versions of himself that felt like a
twist that they waited till the end of
the season to come up with like it
wasn't something that they started out
saying okay this is going to be the
explanation for how this all works out
so when they do reveal who it is then we
can try to figure out how that makes
sense
based on the things that they told us in
past episodes that's always the fun part
of the season like okay we got the
information now how does that actually
make sense but the thing was the last
season we learned the identity of zoo
much earlier in the season we learned
the identity of the man in the yellow
suit much earlier in the season the
reason I think they prolonged this so
much is the identity of savitur is a big
makeup and like it's something that you
want to know but it's not something that
matters it's all about Barry's journey
in recognizing his faults in what his
greater responsibility is to the Speed
Force in to everyone himself the whole
plot of the last episode was all about
how Barry let his family down so he did
that during flashpoint he was selfish he
left his new family to go back and save
his old family so he reignited the hope
in future team flash and brought them
back together so that's going to be part
of his journey the last couple of
episodes so it's almost like they're
saying that this version of Savitt are
is the most selfish version of Barry
somebody who never learned that lesson
that his family is way more important
than what he wants to do if it does turn
out to be Barry the thing though is the
why like why would Barry go so evil why
would he try to kill his past self yes
there was a comic book storyline where
the future flash came back to kill his
past self to erase him from the timeline
but that doesn't seem like what's avatar
is trying to do so like last season what
was zooms big plan
he just wanted all of the speed he
wanted to take Barry Speed be the
fastest thing imaginable and even though
Jay Garrick teased back during episode 9
did sabot R was coming for Barry
because now Barry was power
enough to challenge him it doesn't sound
like Savitt art just wants to be the
fastest version of the flash it sounds
like he wants something that's much
bigger and when he's trying to turn
Kaitlyn to his side he says that he just
wants to help her become her true self
he doesn't threaten her the way that Xun
threatened her the way that zoom got
everybody on earth to to work for him
was through fear if you don't help me I
will totally kill you sabotage hasn't
done that
he's helped unlock metas on earth one
but it seems like that's all he's doing
and then once team flash learned about
him they tried to start stopping him he
tried to stop team flash from stopping
him continuing that mission so this is
the crazy thing in episode 9 all he
wanted to do was unlock all of the metas
everywhere from flash point so that they
would worship Him
so he wants to be the god of speed but
that doesn't mean that he wants to be
the fastest it sounds like he just wants
everybody to love him and it sounds like
he's done this on other world the way
that Jay Garrick talks about it
The Legend of sabotage he's a myth and
then there's the explanation for how he
could be the first speedster get his
speed from the Philosopher's Stone and
still be a future version of Barry
because it sounds like saboteur has
existed in the Speed Force for a while
where the past and the president collide
so there are a couple ways to explain
how Barry could be sabotage but which
other new characters that we haven't met
would have this deep understanding of
the love the team flash has for itself
it has to be a member of team flash and
no I don't think that it's a time
remnant that Barry created because
future Barry sort of had the Hat tip
where he said I tried to create a bunch
of time remnants to go up against avatar
but he killed them all so that was their
way of covering their bases like notes
avatar isn't a time remnant but there's
just been so many things pointing
towards it being very like what would
haunt Wally other than seeing the face
of the person that he loves so much like
he loves Barry he's like his little
brother what would shock you into
becoming catatonic more than seeing your
hero become your greatest villain it's
kind of in the theme of arrow season 5
to prometheus who is actually the big
villain has tried to prove through all
of his actions that Oliver is the true
big bad of the series so it just seems
like there's this big thing about heroes
being portrayed as villains whether
they're actually billing so obviously
our version of Barry that we've been
following this season is not a villain
he does a lot of bad things but he has a
good heart and he's learning from his
eleventh so it just seems like saboteur
is a version of Barry Fit never learn
from those lessons but I'm still open to
the idea of a couple surprises it could
totally be somebody else under that mask
let me know in the comments though but
you know based on all the visual
evidence the way that they cut this
teaser sabot are being a reflection of
Barry in this puddle here who do you
think thats avatar is in what will
happen is is they'll be more flash bonus
videos between now and next week's
episode because there's so much stuff
going on with season four there's a
writer's strike that's happening did a
lot of you guys have asked me about
would that affect the flash if all the
writers in Hollywood went on strike yes
kind of and it would kind of affect the
Teen Titans TV show it would push
everything a little bit but I'll explain
that the next time I post a bonus video
so don't worry it's not nightmare fuel
yet you'll still get flash season 4
stuff at comic-con regardless of what
happens but potentially there could be
some problems so I'll announce the
winner of the flash ring giveaway the
next time I post a DC video while you
wait for that click here for my flash
episode again and click here to learn
all about that Teen Titans TV show thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys in the next
video